Mansour encadre leur formation
ce membre des forces spéciales a quitté
le champ de bataille pour transmettre
son savoir-faire
nous venons pour montrer à ses hommes à
quoi ressemble vraiment les combats pas
la théorie ou des témoignages de seconde
main nous leur faisons profiter de notre
expérience des combats
[Applaudissements]
ce centre d'entraînement joue un rôle
crucial dans la bataille de Herson des
milliers de soldats Ukrainiens sont
passés ici avant d'être envoyé sur le
front
la localisation du centre est tenue
secrète
simple civil membre de la défense
territoriale ou soldat professionnel
ces hommes vont subir au moins deux mois
d'entraînement intensifs avant de
combattre ensemble
à l'entraînement tu vas au bout de
toi-même et après tu sais comment réagir
pendant les combats tu sais que tu peux
compter sur tes frères d'armes qu'ils
seront comment se comporter quel que
soit la situation et nous avons tous un
seul et même objectif libérer notre
terre de ces occupants et rétablir la
paix en Ukraine
savoir évoluer en forêt et sur des
terrains accidentés est une priorité
[Applaudissements]
pour prendre frèresson les forces
ukrainiennes doivent d'abord s'emparer
d'une vaste zone faiblement urbanisée
sur la rivière
dans cette région c'est [__] sont
dans une zone qui ressemble exactement à
ça alors il faut qu'on s'entraîne pour
les encercler et les faire reculer ils
occupent des villages et des villes mais
ils prennent position dans des forêts
dans les champs ou dans des canettes
mais pour reprendre faire ça il faudra
aussi livrer de féroces combat au cœur
même de cette capitale régionale le
renseignement militaire ukrainien estime
que les troupes russes les plus aguerris
tiennent aujourd'hui la ville